[Música]
[Aplausos]
com isso as primeiras imagens que vêm na
sua mente quando penso em paz
talvez aquela praia de certa talvez mata
uma montanha alta o talvez só tem capa
depois daquele dia extremamente
produtivo cheio de muitos resultados que
você vai lá e toma um banho morno
direita na sua calma sabendo que no dia
seguinte não precisa acordar cedo para
bené e se você pudesse ter esse mesmo
sentimento
mesmo quando tudo parecia dar errado
quando tudo na sua volta é tão falso
meu nome está na música soul peruana e
chega no brasil em 2005 com meu filho
uma mala e cinco reais
na época eu mal sabia falar português e
nos sustentávamos da venda dos quadros
que eu pintava como artista de rua 1
centro derrotado nos dois primeiros
meses tudo ia muito bem até um fiscal
levar todo o material que chamou de bem
dele fica nesse momento sentir muita
frustração e muita raiva diante daquilo
que tinha acontecido venda ilícita
comecei a caminhar desesperada de lá pra
cá no centro da cidade
pensando que eu vou comer que vamos
comer como companheira no rio já agora o
que eu faço até ser interrompida por uma
arte que mais parecia uma viragem um
homem totalmente pintado de prata em
cima de um banquinho e com movimentos
que pareciam saídos dos contos de fadas
estava bem na minha frente era uma
estátua viva nesse momento eu senti meu
coração bater mais forte de uma certeza
de que eu tinha sido treinada pelo
universo parecer ser aquela profissão
invadiu todo meu cérebro
veja quando era pequena eu era proibida
de fazer qualquer tipo de arte
meu pai era um artista frustrado e ele
tinha muito medo de milton
a artista como ele pois ele nunca tinha
conseguido sustentar a família com arte
por causa disso ele não comprava lápis
de cor me impedia de desenhar de fazer
teatro na escola e como maneira de
prevenir que a sua filha cometesse o
mesmo erro ele me deixava de castigo
cada vez que eu desobedecia que
desobedecia muito
qual era o cache ele me deixava em p
em silêncio estática em cima de um
banquinho no canto na fala olhando para
a parede
dois dias depois de ter visto aquele
homem pintado de prata em cima de um
banquinho que estava em cima de um
banquinho era eu a pessoa que menos
queria que eu me tornasse artista foi a
que mais me treino para aquela profissão
havia algo inexplicável por trás da arte
da rua do silêncio que uma face a
acordar todo dia com passes o que isso
no rosto
muitas emoções despertá la de mim e das
pessoas que me observava as pessoas
caminham pela rua como o sumiço fazendo
compras e quando me amparava era como se
despertar se neste momento eles paravam
por um instante observando que ficava
estáticas em silêncio
acho que nesse momento ela se tornava
estado algumas pessoas começaram a
chorar sem saber o motivo
outras sorri encantadas e as crianças
elas nunca sabia se você é um anjo -
fator
no meio da correria da lista de ações
para fazer era quando vinha uma estátua
viva que elas podiam parar por um
instante fazer uma pausa e se conectar
com agora
isso tornará meu dia mágico em poucas
meses muitas pessoas me contrataram para
me apresentar em eventos nas recepções
de casamentos aniversários festas de
debutantes era horas fazendo minha arte
do início até o fim de cada evento sob
observação no tudo aquilo que acontecia
e eu te garanto não existe uma pessoa
que saiba mais sobre a prova
foi uma festa do que aquela que fica
observando do início até o fim
levando tudo como acontece por isso seis
meses depois eu tinha minha própria
produtora de eventos e nem ele recriava
toda a magia da estátua viva do centro
de são paulo
só que dentro das tradicionais e chapas
redes sociais
começamos fazer sucesso um evento desses
eventos em eventos 101 102 103 e
perdendo conta do quanto trabalhava
me perdi a minha mesa eu ficava o dia
inteiro 56 não tinha parado um instante
para comer tudo era mais importante até
mesmo os 60 cigarros que fumava por dia
é claro que se descuidou se tornou será
é claro que a cidade se tornou insônia
é claro que a frustração diante de tanta
insatisfação se tornou depressão
nesse momento o psb de que ter
resultados não era a mesma coisa que
tenha sucesso
eu percebi que tendo a vida que eu tinha
quanto mais eu ganhava mais me perdi
você sabe às vezes a gente quer
desbravar o mundo afora e nos esquecemos
do infinito mundo que somos
eu tinha muito orgulho do que eu tinha
construído do zero mas eu tinha certeza
de que poderia construir tudo de novo
mas antes anderson precisava reconstruir
o que eu tinha destruído a mim eu
precisava de um tempo de uma pausa e
como maneira de me reconectar com aquilo
que eu tinha perdido eu voltei a me
aventurar no universo novamente das
moedinhas que eu ganhava como estátua
viva no centro da cidade
minha mãe sempre diz de pequena que eu
seria uma menina de ouro somos e se
referia isso eu sonhei desde pequena
viajar para muitos lugares distantes mas
eu nunca imaginei que chegaria tão longe
dentro de mim e por mais que seja
difícil de imaginar foi a arte à rua e o
silêncio a mais apaixonante de todas as
minhas aventuras pois foi um sempre de
sao paulo ironicamente que eu pude
encontrar a paz no meio do caos
[Música]
algumas pessoas fazem longas viagens
para a tailândia ilhas china para
encontrar respostas para se reencontrar
mas meu retiro e retiro urbano
eu retiro foi em cima de um banquinho
onde ironicamente pude encontrar paz no
meio do caos
qual é o seu caos
independente de qual seja a resposta é
possível encontrar paz no meio dele
foram mais de 10 mil horas apresentando
como estátua viva no centro de são paulo
e nesse tempo todo inumeráveis
aprendizados
mas eu aprendi três coisas que me
permitiram ver que era possível
encontrar paz no meio do caos
eu quero dividir esse surpreendidos com
você
o primeiro prende sábado
aprendi a experimentar tudo como se
fosse a primeira vez
a estátua viva e um ser encantado ele
compra a vida cada vez que o humano da
vida ele e depois ele se torna estátua
viva novamente e todas as memórias deles
são apagadas tem o som da primeira
moradia
você percebe o ar entrando pelo teu
corpo pela primeira vez que acompanha o
percurso que ele toma depois acontece
uma pausa e depois assim como aquele ar
entrou ele sai respirar
no fundo os batimentos o teu coração que
na praça sentir até na pontinha dos
dedos os teus ouvidos acorda muito
alguns graves alguns segundos alguns
distantes alguns próximos mas todos
diferentes
de repente o bem tocar o rosto
pela primeira vez o vento vai o vento
bem o universo também respira
nesse momento você abra seus olhos e
consegui ver pela primeira vez a pessoa
que te deu à filha quando você
experimenta tudo como se fosse a
primeira vez
ordinário se torna extraordinário
os julgamentos diminui essa atualmente é
calma você se conecta com o crescente e
qualquer coisa por mais comum que seja
se torna realmente extraordinária
esse sentimento me trazia tanta passa
desfaçam que eu comecei a levar em
outras áreas momentos da minha vida no
meio do trânsito no caos não tenha
apertado quando estava com raiva quando
estava brincando com o meu filho
isso me trazia paz no meio do caos como
seria se você neste momento sentir sua
respiração pela primeira vez
também aprendi de que o corpo
podia ser uma âncora para permanecer no
presente onde estava apresentando o são
paulo nas ruas ea minha mente foi longe
você sabe comecei a lembrar as coisas do
passado pensei coisas do futuro e de
repente uma criancinha eleitor mãe
amanda se mexendo
levei um susto fiquei apavorada a minha
mão começou a mexer ainda mais com a
respiração fica ofegante o meu
pensamento entre o passado eo futuro a
minha atenção estava totalmente voltada
aquilo que as pessoas estavam pensando
ea minha mão sobre minha cada vez mais
nesse momento percebi que minha atenção
que minha mente estava fora do meu corpo
estava folha do meu corpo
aí eu decidir voltar meu corpo como se
eu decidisse investir lio e ao inspirar
contraiu meus pés eu respirar os
relaxing depois
a vez das panturrilhas e assim parte por
parte do meu corpo
contraiu inspirar e eu é falar relaxava
quando cheguei até a minha mão ela
estava calma novamente assim como minha
respiração que assim como minha mente
como se fossem uma coisa só duas faces
da mesma moeda
nesse momento percebi que quando você se
conecta com o seu corpo você se conecta
também como presente e claro
o corpo está no passado o corpo está no
futuro não lhe o corpo estava presente
no único tempo real que insiste nesse
momento percebi que o seu corpo uma
âncora para permanecer aqui agora e
quando a gente sabe disso é possível
meditar em qualquer hora e em qualquer
lugar
veja só a meditação é uma coisa que se
pode ensinar através de palavras ele
precisa ser experimentado por isso eu
vou te convidar para fazer uma pequena
rápida experiência neste momento
rapidamente fica de pé muito bem agora
que inspire profundamente ea oea salar
fecha os olhos da garota somente permite
que minha voz o conduza para esta viagem
e para que tal somente preste atenção no
seu corpo e inspire e relaxa deixando
tensionado apenas os músculos que
precisa para ficar em pé
e faça isso mais uma vez e inspire e
relaxe
faça o mesmo com os músculos do rosto
relaxando a testa bochechas e maxilar
a sua mente vencer que tando no meio
você está numa grande cidade
especificamente no meio de uma grande
cidade
você é uma estátua viva e se posicionam
no cruzamento das duas ruas muito
movimentadas
vocês estão de costas para os carros que
passam de um lado para o outro na sua
frente uma larga calçada muitas 9 e
claro
op muitas pessoas nunca
mas outras nem tanto
isso é bom nível e no meio desse caos
uma mãe com uma criança se aproxima
rolim cantar
a ordem é colocar aqui filha você
respirar profundamente e dá seu primeiro
fôlego de vida você move com aquilo
somente a mão e aproxima do pei para
reverenciar a receber pequenos certo por
ter levado a vida gratidão
enquanto ela se arrasta sem deixar de
olhar pra você você se torna estátua
novamente
preste atenção ao vai e vem da sua
respiração quer ser o caminho que o ar
para ocorrem socopo quer ser a pausa que
existe entre a inspiração ea espécie
a tv se pessoalmente significa ir você
volta a atenção somente para a sua
respiração permita que sua respiração se
torna é tão calma até você conseguir
sentir os batimentos o seu coração agora
respire profundamente não é falar a
nossa mente abrir seus olhos por alguns
minutos você experimentou um pouquinho
daquilo que eu vi vencer agora pessoa
pra você sentar pois ainda tenho que
compartilhar com você
o terceiro precisado que através da
gratidão é possível ressignificar a
nossa família
vocês ouviram a criança a moedinha
importa 65 reais ou cinco centavos
as pessoas não vêm de entregar apenas
uma moedinha dentro de um pote elas te
dão vida eu sentia literalmente gratidão
a vida e quando o reverenciava com todo
o meu corpo levantar o leva para os
olhos daquela pessoa e eu percebia no
outro o mesmo sentimento enquanto estava
sendo grato à vida a outra pessoa estava
sendo grata a pausa que isso era mágico
dizem que faz muito bem
todo dia ou levantar sermos gratos à
vida que a química do nosso cérebro se
altera de que você passa a ter mais
vitalidade otimismo para ser pela vida
imagina o que acontece quando você faz
isso umas 300 vezes por dia tão tilt na
cabeça e tudo é configurado
de repente você percebe que a escola é a
vida e que diante de cada problema há um
aprendizado
e foi com esse novo olhar que perceber
as diversas situações do meu passado que
tinha me calçada
e pude sentir gratidão a meu pai pelo
treinamento que ele me fez ainda quando
era pequena
gratidão ao fiscal por levar todo o meu
material pois assim eu pude ver a
estátua viva gratidão a correria pois eu
pude dar assim valor atitude e perceber
que descanso também faz parte do
trabalho
gratidão a tudo o que aconteceu ea tudo
pelo qual eu passei pois graças a tudo
isso é que o poço de ser agora pra você
neste momento ímpar na sua mente e no
seu coração porque paz interior
independe do caos esta gratidão
[Aplausos]
[Música]